all right welcome back to the show let's
uh let's hear from some folks
it is the uh i guess sort of
thanksgiving edition
of live calls hitting us earlier this
week because we will be off on thursday
and friday for the thanksgiving holiday
we are taking calls via discord
davidpakman.com slash discord
d-i-s-c-o-r-d
and we have uh all sorts of different
people
who are interested in chatting today
let's start
with andrew from miami andrew from miami
you're on the air
hi david how's it going can you hear me
yes i can
great i was wondering what your opinion
was of remember when bloomberg ran in
the democratic
primary yeah he threw in like a billion
dollars or something right
i think it was um i think it was a 150
or 200 million certainly
oh no i think reporting from washington
post new york times said it was around
900
million oh well maybe it is yeah i'm not
saying you're wrong i i had not heard
that number but it's conceivable
sure and then during the actual
presidential election you only threw in
about
100 million in one state
i found that interesting because he said
that trump was an existential threat to
that democracy and didn't and i think he
said he was going to do like
everything possible to get biden elected
and he didn't
i mean listen 100 million is nothing to
sneeze at obviously but for a guy
with his wealth he could certainly have
have put in
way more for sure and i think that's why
people are saying things like
you know eat the rich and whatnot but i
mean i also saw even on the democratic
side
like obama only came out around two or
three weeks before the election
and then afterward he has this book tour
where he's on every major news station
isn't that pretty interesting yeah i'm i
find the obama thing less surprising i
mean i think during the primary
obama's approach was clear which was
he's not going to get involved
close to the primary or before it's
decided because he wants to be able to
credibly support whoever the nominee is
and if he ends up
you know endorsing someone during the
primary who doesn't end up being the
nominee it could just hurt his ability
to campaign for them i do
you're right that obama was only on the
physical campaign trail for a couple of
weeks
but i think a lot of that was that it
there was really no in-person
campaigning being done on the democratic
side for a while because of the virus
he you know obama did speak at the dnc
which was remote i i
that that's less of a flag to me the
bloomberg thing it's just like he was
obviously just dishonest about how
involved he was going to be
and helping the eventual nominee win he
just lied
right definitely cool yeah thanks for
taking my question i appreciate it
all right andrew from miami great to
hear from you we are taking calls
via discord at davidpakman.com
discord i'm really excited that
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
i sleep on a helix mattress at home i
absolutely love it and that's why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position your back pain issues
you might have and
their tool matched me with a mattress
that is perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you first
hand every helix mattress comes with a
10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video